[Musique]
réussir à organiser une manifestation
avec les cinquante quatre maires des
trois gouvernorats c'est à dire les îles
de ce pays dans un contexte de crise
sanitaire a été un vrai défi avec la
mise en place d'une nouvelle
constitution aux comores ses maillons de
l'organisation du pays doivent
maintenant être formés
pendant la durée de nos mandants alors
là je profite cette occasion pour
monsieur tout d'abord nos précédé ses
soeurs le processeur qui ont quand même
élaboré ce projet pour que ce soit
réalisé aujourd'hui c'est très bien que
les nerfs et telma très important dans
la vie au niveau de communauté alors
parce qu'il a affronté beaucoup de
difficultés à lille va cirer le banc des
sociabilités très élargie vers les
communes
donc il devait quand même être patients
et solidaires et unis les discours
peuvent alors commencer tous fiers de
cette opération qui a pris plusieurs
années à se concrétiser
vraiment ce jour triste les propres
actions par lesquels le gouvernement de
l'humain de croire solo qui sont des
chefs d etat son excellence azali
assoumani avait promis les comores font
partie de l'histoire du peuplement de la
réunion
[Musique]
de nombreuses familles réunionnaises ont
des patronymes comoriens corréler les
réels besoins de ce pays ami à la france
réunion est clairement l'objectif
ainsi l'université des comores a piloté
le contenu pédagogique de ces formations
les collectivités réunionnaises ont
elles apporté leur expertise
autre symbole ça a été notre volonté que
ce projet soit étroitement conçu
ensemble mise en oeuvre conjointement
la nation va pouvoir accéder à beaucoup
de pratique de bonnes pratiques et un
savoir faire nouveaux qui vont tous nous
apporter un bien-être comoriens mesdames
et messieurs les autorités
l'après midi ils étaient tous présents
de l'autre côté de la ville pour le
début de la formation la
décentralisation et notament majeur pour
l'avenir du pays
le baiser surtout c'est de pouvoir
sensibiliser notre population afin de
pouvoir comprendre qu'est-ce que la
décentralisation
la formation sera très bénéfique pour
les bénéficiaires
c'est une question de volonté maintenant
il faut que chacun se met vraiment à
en moins en bonne position d'essayer de
devoir d'essayer de lancer de finir que
d'être attractif pour travailler par
simple ses actions de coopération aurons
d'autres portes et demain avec notamment
la mise en place d'un centre de
formation des élus ou encore le
développement de la francophonie à
travers la formation des enseignants
comoriens
[Musique]